That's will happen. The Joe Rogan
experience. Uh, well listen Corey,
you're a bad mother fucker. I appreciate
you coming here. It's just fun.
It's fun talk. Do you want to talk
on more? We did three hours, man,
but we talk all MMA
to, to me. Let's do it.
Okay.
Let's talk about a,
but who you told me you're going on your
first elk hunting trip this year. Yep.
Getting out to Montana, Montana. We're
part. Is it around? I can't remember.
So he gave me the code
to put into the DNR site.
Are you using the different set because
you use it a light set up out there for,
but that's for target right here.
I got 60 pounds.
Just like 62 or 63 and how many grains
arrows you a like that's a to 60 yeah,
that's a really lie
there. Oh Man. I'll use,
when I go out there for Elka and I used
it at 300 so I got the grizzly stick
weighted tips, whatever, 300 grains,
that's it. That's usually what I shoot.
300 grain.
I shoot five 25 525 grains.
I should pull 84 pounds.
I like a the tip and everything
and I don't know what it is,
but the answer is 300 wait, I don't
wait. Yeah, with everything. Yeah.
I've have to get to scale how I make my
own arrows and the basement and all that.
But I just don't have the scale to
see how much your way at the end.
Are you trying to do that for speed?
Is that why you have the light grains?
That's just what the guy,
my guy an narrows the hats.
Hats I'm wearing actually in Vegas. I'm
going to connect you to John. Dudley.
I mean I know you've
already talked to him,
but I want to get you guys together next
time you're anywhere near here and he's
in or if you're in
Vegas and he's in Vegas,
I'm going to get you guys together
and have them coach you and help you.
Cause I already, I already see
that. You, you very accurate.
You know when we're playing
techno hunt, you're, you know,
scoring in the vitals every single
time, you know, except for one,
one little one body, one body shot.
But even that's a dead elk where he,
where he hit it. But John can
help you tremendously. He, he'll,
he'll tighten up your shit.
You know, I see his videos,
I study that stuff all the
time. But again, he's like
the Mark Henry of archery.
I see it.
Yeah.
And hundred yard shot through the
Kettlebell and target that I'll tell her
friends all the time.
Like I was most amazing thing I've
ever seen the hold up this big.
He went through an era only operation.
Yup.
It's like you don't see people
shooting like cam is good too,
but I'm not saying he couldn't do it,
but I don't camp could do it too.
They have a cam to other post videos
shooting through kettlebells and it's like
some crazy videos too.
But I mean it's just that level of
commitment where they're just constantly
training, constantly doing. And John
is also just such a fantastic coach.
You know,
he's so good at the understanding archery
fundamentals and explaining it to you,
the positioning and it's very much like
martial arts in that we would make a few
little changes and it does the world
of difference. I'm willing to learn.
Yeah. Most of the time I'm
learning on the fly, like my dad,
we learn how to shoot together and I was
like 12 one of his buddies was like, oh,
ever did archery,
took him to the rain,
she got me a browning and
I was a kid and you know,
I was shooting at it
three shooting with him.
It's kind of like what I learned was
from what he learned. But if you know my
dad,
everything other than work,
everything is kind of like ghetto
guys are calling the ghetto Cabo.
We had horses and everything and it was
just like the way you see people do it
on TV when that was not the way my dad
learned how to arrange horses and grab
voices and sell them up and everything
was kind of ghetto ghetto cow boy,
you know? So now when I go back from
things I learned and I tell him,
cause like you said, you see my answer
cause I'm all hunting, you know, playing,
fighting. I'm hunting
constantly. He was like,
where'd you learn is it's just watching
videos and I go home with somebody
else's instead of talking
like I talk about what I know.
But most honestly I listened to guys
talk and I ask a question like yeah,
like I don't know what it is but
I make it seem like I do. But yes.
What are you thinking about that and you
break it down. I had no clue about that.
Learn how to feel dressed. My first deer
in Texas with these guys, hero sports,
a bunch of veterans, we go out, they
asked me and just in case you that's,
I got closer gates,
you hunting with those guys?
We've worked with veterans with amputated
legs or mental problems, whatever.
Just listening to a store and we kill
the deer like they'd been hiding they
whole life.
They grew up as key.
So field dressing and how to call and
like you shooting the rifle was like,
oh you go to just website and
if you got 110 grade a bullet,
it shows you here at 300 yards.
Aim on this cross here. And like,
and I learned different
stuff from those guys.
Veterans that do this stuff for a living.
They ain't had been in the war and
learn how to shoot a gun then God,
these are like John, Debbie.
I see his videos and his uh,
not in school and Knox and what not
watching, stuff like that. Like you said,
you ever had any coaching?
Like what I do is just practice over
and over and over and I'm at the range,
the owner, Mike K and m, he'll
come out and be like, oh,
kind of try to turn your head a little
bit more. I didn't have kisser button.
Put a kisser button though that a forced
you to turn your head and you need to
be strict with the line straight down
and think about pushing his lifeline
through and just stuff like that. And
I just practice, I guess I'm shooting.
I used to shoot at least a
hundred miles a day. Like I said,
I'll pop that truck bit down,
put the radio on your sat there and shoot.
I shot one time so long I couldn't move
my neck back the next morning I fell
asleep and I woke up.
I could not,
I was stuck like I didn't even train
because I was stuck on my head turned like
this cause my neck got tight cause I was
crunched up here and doing this like I
wasn't supposed to. But
it all tightened up. Yeah.
And also I'm learning the hard way was
like I went Turkey hunting this year,
this last week. Archery Turkey. Yeah.
Never Been Turkey hunting before.
I've only seen on youtube or hurt somebody
telling me at the trade show great
American outdoors and it
just sounds so interesting.
And I saw youtube and ordered all the
stuff I need decoys and I was teaching
myself watching videos knock the first
day I slate call him boss called.
I don't know. That's not
right now. I came to that,
now I'll put it on the slate and it
sounded like an actual Turkey call.
And like I'm good in a week cause
I just steady and try. Right.
So stuff like that. So I just look
forward to fuck with those hex suits.
The who
suit you noted as HTCs. It's
a, especially with birds,
birds, you know, birds can navigate
using magnetics. They, they use,
they use like the magnetic
pole to electromagnetic fields.
It's been proven that can register and
they see electric sense electromagnetic
fields. And they think that birds in
particular and, and sea creatures too,
like they use it with a scuba divers and,
and a spear fishermen
and people like that.
There's a suit that blocks
the electromagnetic signal
that your body gives off.
And uh, it's PR supposedly particularly
effective with Turkeys who, you know,
are very,
uh,
they see very well and they see
things movement and they're very,
very skiddish and they see any weird shit.
They just get the fuck out of there.
But, um, this guy, Mike's linkerd, who's
one of the guys who created the heck suit,
he hunts a turkeys with no blind.
He just sits out in the field with
this heck suit on that blocks the
electromagnet magnetic signal men.
He puts Cammo on over the heck suit and
there's videos of him doing this. Man,
it's kind of crazy. You know, this
is a, I gotta check that. Yeah,
this is him sitting there.
So he's sitting with this heck suit on
right in front of these turkeys. Now,
you know,
as well as I know that most of the time
if you are right in front of a Turkey
like that, they'll get the fuck out
of Dodge Dakota thing they put over.
But he's not, he doesn't have that. They
don't got the coin is, hey, yeah, I mean,
he's babbling behind the giant body
behind him and he's, he's moving.
But the idea is that it can't see the
electromagnetic signal that you're giving
off. There's a lot of videos on
it. It's super controversial,
but a Dudley swears by it.
John Dudley swears by,
and a lot of other folks do too. Um,
uh, Shane Dorian. Yeah, I think it does.
I think it works for everything. I think
animals can sense something. I mean,
it's not everything, right? I mean,
you still can't be downwind or
upwind, you know, if, if you,
if you are wind comes and catches them,
they're gonna smell you and they're
going to get the fuck out of there.
But it's a, and what does that,
another camera, Jesus Christ.
That's a great picture. Like that's
a perfect example of how flow works,
right? That picture is trip, but you gotta
if you try to take that picture of me,
you tried that, you're going to see me.
It's like a perfect, yeah. And of course,
I mean it's the perfect type of leaves,
the perfect angle, the perfect lighting.
You know, it's probably fucked
with a little, but you know, the,
the heck suit is a very
controversial thing,
but people smarter than me say it works.
It really works with sea creatures
for some reason with, um,
things in the water because you know,
animals,
they have that a lateral line or fish
rather have that lateral line and they,
they sense electrical signals that are
coming off of a creatures that are in the
water. And so scuba divers
swear by this fucking the suit.
It's interesting stuff. Yeah. Hurt
and everything hurt. I'm like, wait,
I'll get them to send you some.
Yeah, for sure. Well, like I said,
I listened to Dudley when it comes to
every, I'm, you know, I'm like you,
when it comes to martial arts,
if someone's teaching me something,
I just listened. I don't,
I don't second gas.
And when a guy is wise's him says
that it works, I'm curious about it.
At least try it before I knock.
You don't work for me. They like,
maybe it's just I'm doing something wrong
and then they come and show me and it
still don't work. It's gonna like I
don't believe it, but if it works,
I'm going to have a particular,
uh, Cammo company right now.
Appreciate thicker CIC is the best. Yeah,
I love it. They'll abandon me. I got,
they gave me a little pro deal 50% off
and that's great. So it worked out.
I love it. It's still expensive,
but it's worth it. Yeah.
They just have so much engineering and
their shit. And guys like John Barklow,
the guy was what the designer that does
all the protesting and cold weather,
and you ever see the cold water immersion
test they've done with their shit.
He's got a rewarming drilled that he put
online explaining to people what you do
if you're in cold conditions
and you fall into the water,
like how to read warm yourself.
It's got a whole video where he did it.
They jumped into this icy
river and then yet, nope.
And then clowned out. And you know, the,
the suits are designed in a lot of the
clothing is designed to allow you to
survive and that sort of a situation. But
you know, you have to know how to do it,
how to go about it. See,
here's, there's John and, uh,
this guy that he's with
and they just dumped it.
There's John on the right and they'd
dump themselves in this freezing fucking
water and then get out. And then they
put on sleeping bags and got in the tent.
And
let me tell you right now,
that's when the Wpas Geo, ah,
you're not gonna see no black man,
no frozen waters.
You can prove [inaudible] brother and no,
I was ready to prove a point. Um,
well he's educating people though.
See when he was in the military,
that's what he did.
He taught cold weather survival.
He's, he's so thorough too.
And you know,
and he's one of the reasons why sit cause
gear so well engineered and designed
because they've got a guy like him that's
a telling them how to design things.
And he's a hunter too. He hunted with me
last year. I hunted elk with him and uh,
in Utah,
I'm actually going to get the test out.
Like my buddy told me before, like,
I promise you thicker, you get that
warm and stuff, no matter how coat,
you're not going to get cold, like the
best shit. So I'm going, uh, Saskatchewan,
Canada for white tail in November.
Yeah, right. They got and he told me,
he say the case, he's like, it's not that
bad. It was kind of cool. It was not bad.
He was like sometimes like negative
two. I'm like, that's fucking back.
Are you calling?
Right.
Well I've got an extra body suit
for you so I'm going to get there.
Super warm gear and try it out.
And he said, if it don't worry,
I'll let you use the body suit.
But yeah,
well you might need the body
suit and Saskatchewan is fucking,
I'm going to test and see if it really
works. I might see you boys video,
check it out.
That candidate colds a different cold,
you know those people are hardy folks
there. You went out there and uh,
June for the bear hand. Actually me and
my dad in the mornings it was cold. Yeah.
And our time day,
the sun come out and then we go to the
top of the mountain to the sea glass and
you know, man fast, like instantly
hands froze. I'm in a truck in the heat.
He just out there chilling in his t shirt.
This is how they do this.
Just used to it. Yeah. Now will you,
when you were up there was that
spot and stalk or, yeah. Yeah.
So you catching them when they were coming
out of the dens and eating grass have
to go up to the top of the view point.
That's how my mom and we looked at me,
him and my dad,
he had the spotting scope and we both
from Manaca he said just look for a black
guy.
You see something you're telling me.
And I put the spotting scope scope on
it and see ever see a style or a bear we
can get, you don't have something
like office hours cut her cubs.
We're not shooting us.
We only want old males and it's crazy
cause it's a 30 minute drive to the top of
the mountain. So after we seal it
might look like it's right there.
It's like like an hour to get down
there and we've got a park and they,
we still got walked 2030 minutes
and hope he's still in that area.
You know what I mean? Like I said, we
came across elk, we came across cougars,
all kinds of stuff,
but you get an that bear was gone and we
tie back to the truck back to the time
we did it all day to like it got
dark and take us till midnight,
whatever to get home cause it was so
far into the mountains and it was great
like I said, but it walked in and I
had the wrong boots. I like work boots.
My cat stuff was burned
in the first day but,
and I'm with the head guy is I don't
like driving. I was like walking a lot.
So we did a whole lot of walk. He's like,
I figured you'd be in the UFC fighter.
I can test you. I never had a guys
athletic as you that's able to walk.
Most people are overweight
or not athletics.
They want to go a little bit and it's
time to go to the trip. Like you,
I can test you out a lot of cardio man.
Those were you telling man,
I never been so strong in my life.
That's my mom said like Mr Overtime, 25,
eight like Bruh, you ain't
did it Mama. It's different.
It's different walking up those hills
and those guys that get used to it,
those very specific muscles that you use
when you're constantly hiking up hills
that you said you did a
black per home before.
I did a few in a bow or rifle in um,
uh,
north of Alberta with uh, my friends,
uh, John and Jen, the rivets up there.
They've got a great camp up there.
I just don't have the time to get
away for that many camps, you know?
And I prefer elk hunting a year.
I'm going to do for this year,
for this year or two elk.
One axis deer and one mule deer.
Now what about Saskatchewan
white till you seen those? Fuck,
what would you what you do it?
Yeah, we'll do it. I'll do it.
He do ever want to see,
I can't cause I do have something
scheduled in November already. Oh,
are you telling me when I can sell more
than 100 a month? I'll get divorced.
My kids will beat me up.
I'm on the verge of that already.
I'm on every morning, I get
up four o'clock she just
put the baby back to sleep.
I'm up making noise.
Wish me luck. I'll see you when I get
back. I know they don't like it, man.
It's funny, but I get it. But it's,
it's one of those things that
just takes a lot of time.
Like if you're going to go on a
hunting trip, it's seven days away,
you know you have seven days and you're
going to be probably somewhere where
there's no cell phone signal. But for
me, man, it's very valuable for my head.
I, I, I've, I recenter
out there. I get it man.
There's fucking animals chasing deer and
did things or trying to survive and it
just puts everything in perspective for
me when I'm sneaking up on an elk and
I'm on Tiptoe tiptoeing through the grass
and I'm just trying to get inside like
60 70 yards just to get a good shot off
and I'm trying to make sure the wind is
ride and I'm not thinking about anything
else, man, nothing. Why draw back?
And I sent her my pin and you know on,
I put,
I'm looking through the peep site and
everything's right and the housing's level
and I've got my anchor point and I'm
pulling up my back muscles and I'm just
concentrating on that spot.
Aim Small, Ms. Small it all,
the whole world goes away.
The world goes away and when that
Arrow finds that crease and sinks right
through the, and you see those
fledglings disappear and you're like, ah,
we fucking did it.
Cause some people will never understand
like why would you be happy you killed
an animal because it's so hard to do. It's
not that you're happy, the animals die,
you happy you did it. It's a
relief. It's so hard to do.
It's like people don't understand like
to maintain calmness and stillness when
you're drawing on an animal.
It's not like a rifle.
I've shot things with the
rifle and it's not easy.
It's more hard than people think it is,
but it's way easier than using a bow.
It's not even close.
So you've got to draw back
without being spotted. Yeah.
Then you've got a hold steady. Yup.
The rifle was kind of you guys sticks.
Fantastic. Put your shoulder. Like I said,
it ain't easy but you find a cross
hair at once. You get it settled
on that pool.
I pull it down so they don't see me.
So right now I'm starting to shake.
I've been held like the one,
I hit three minutes and 41 seconds.
I had a record and I held his book coming.
He kept stopping like I feel my back so
I had to get up and I'll put it down.
I'm like wobbly and I posted a video
after that killed people wonder why I'm so
proud of my kids. Like do you know
what it's like being 235 pounds,
six three in a tree, not being
spotted hold or both. You know,
hey you going to control your breathing
and one role moving my head, if I go to,
it's something he see my hat,
mood or silhouette, he's gone.
It's like literally like I post a
video and it looked like a picture,
like just me holding and it looked like
a picture cause I never moved. Like,
I don't think anybody understands how
hard it is to be as big as I am all up in
the tree with a climber.
I'm using the cloud so that's hard too.
And Get up and just sit still. The wind
blowing everything. You can't sway.
You sit, everything has to
be right. It's an art to it.
People never know.
They'll never know unless they do it.
It's one of those things and many people
that get mad at people that do it are
meat eaters,
which drives me crazy.
They think there's something wrong
with killing wild animals like that.
That's the best way to do it
because these animals, first of all,
they're going to, you're going
to get organic, real wild
meat. It's better for you.
Second of all,
like these animals lived a real life.
They're not like came in a butcher shop
after I got the band, me and my dad got
and we post a picture and uh, his lady,
she's in the same stuff in the
company and I know she eats meat.
I've seen her at a barbecue, her and
her husband like pound and burgers.
And I posted the picture, shit, I can't
believe you are no longer fall. You.
How could you dare go in a while
and kill a bear to eat it? I said,
don't you eat burgers?
Out of that,
you went and got a cattle that somebody
took and chained up and slaughter you
rather that than me going out and
getting them the most natural way ever.
Not only that serious.
If you love animals,
you got to kill bears because
they eat everything. They eat.
50% of all the deer fawns and El Calves,
they get killed by bears.
50% of them,
like I post a picture of killing a
coyote wants and they're like, oh,
did you get a coyote? Didn't do anything
to you, but the thing they didn't see.
I posted a video a week later I killed
the cow as he was chasing down a dope.
He was like trying to get him and I,
I saw and I swung at him right when he
came out. POW flipped him and it was open.
I saved the deer's life. Boy y'all
saw was the picture of the Kylie.
What you can't eat them. Yeah.
But I saved the other wildlife.
They said you'll never
make everybody happy.
You can't make anybody happy that doesn't
understand hunting, that's for sure.
They, they have this perception of it from
movies and from a lot of those redneck
stupid TV shows where,
you know, they just don't,
they don't portray
hunting in a positive way.
And so people get this
negative impression about it.
But I think with more people like you,
elite athletes that are getting into a
Bo Jackson is a big bow hunter. You know,
there's a lot of boners now that are,
you know,
that we're just athletes
and they realize like, wow,
this is thrilling and exciting and
then it's the best meat in the world.
So you have so many pros
and it's the most, yeah,
I think it's the most ethical way to eat
meat because you going out and getting
it yourself, you're not hiring
some supermarket hit man.
You're doing it yourself.
Right. That's the thing. When
my youtube has the main point,
ain't no about hunting.
It's more like one,
a black guy in her community to show her.
It was more than just killing.
Like I so far the one and now is a Turkey
this whole week I'm out there but I
didn't kill anything.
But it's more showing you that it's more
like you see the deer walk up to a few,
the sun coming up, the sand going
down all this and editing it.
I'm doing it all myself now.
Do you think you'll have a career in
that after you get done with [inaudible]?
I don't.
Like I tell when I meet people at the
shows that work willing to work with me
like I don't know. What do you want?
Like I don't want them money or anything.
I just want you to help if you can,
let me use one of your gear on
your thing and I advertise it.
I put you a little link at the beginning.
Tack the Cam, both creative people.
I usually just put a thing on there
cause I don't want money but because I'm
just a fighter,
I'm not a hunter but I love the sport.
You know I love hunting and you share,
you help advertise whatever.
I'm just wanting to get as well as
well and on the lamb and fighting.
I want the same thing in hunting and with
that dudes I had to bring other people
cause I see like when
I go to the boat shop,
people ask all the time like I'm in today.
I was in the hotel on my button like oh
you got a gig somewhere without a guitar?
Like no, it's a bow and arrow. He said
guy say oh and there he look at it. Yeah.
Huh. All that. I love hunting.
Especially when you see me.
Like I told my wife I'm going to first
person on Joe Rogan shooting techno thing
with Jordan's a do rag or would a bowl.
It don't work that way
where you're lagging and Jordan, it's
very that guy on the streets with sounds.
But then you see me with a bow or a gun.
I want to be the first guy to ever shoot
techno hot wearing a do rag and a bow.
You mark and Jordan's will direct wavy.
Someone's done that.
Before I went to do rack, you might
get somebody to do rag [inaudible].
Joe Reg Jones by the do rag. It's true.
I got them both. You've got the Combo,
you know what I mean? So that's thing
I want people to see what the show,
not about hunting.
Just you don't have to be
the typical what people see.
You see country guys,
cowboy has cowboy boots,
kicked shit kickers and they trucks.
I think that's the guy
you expect to be a hunter.
The guy walk around and came up.
I want somebody to see because people find
out how like you, I love it. That's it.
When people see a top level UFC fight or
doing it and they're like, Whoa, really?
Like this is life. Yeah, that's, I
love that. You love it man. It's, it's,
it means a lot to me,
man.
I I think that positive role models like
you are what the sport needs to change
people's, but I don't want to say sport
cause I don't think hunting is a sport,
let's call it a disorder. A culture
to change people's perceptions of it.
The positive people like you that are
elite athletes and just for people to get
a chance to see like, hey, this is the,
I mean I'm not encouraging
everyone to do it,
but I think there's a lot of
people that would love that.
I've never tried it because they may be
don't have an understanding of what it
actually is. So if they see
you, I'll see the videos.
Are you doing like Chad Mendez? We'll
deep. He's deepened, but that's all.
I love it. He loves it.
That's all he wants to do.
I mean he basically is fighting to pay
for his hunting career, you know? Yeah.
Plan. Oh hey found it. I said this
is just scouting and stuff. Yeah,
but right now I got this in Jersey. Yeah.
This is like behind my house I believe.
Yet. Mavens. Huh? It's all
a lot of purchase. I can see
everybody think everything.
I post posted stuff.
I got hooked,
know a lot of stuff I've got I purchased
because that's what I like to use.
I'll have maybe even hook you up Brandon
Weaver way yet. I actually met him.
I met him at the gray. I do
it. That's my bottom. Me Great.
Like I tried to stuff stand like I'm
a purchase this. Oh that's good man.
Good for you. They make
great shit. I mean,
there's a lot of great companies
out there. The Guy Filming,
he was a teammate of mine that hunts, but
when the guy, I talked to frank Yeager,
he said he wanted to do it. Somebody gave
him a bowl. It's like, give me a boat.
I set it up. I'll show you how to
get, I got all my guys. Tell them all,
send the link. Um, do you hunter
safety car and I take you out.
I'll film it and I'll show you how to
do it real. Like my buddies in Jersey,
he's a jersey shore Greedo type guy.
But like I said,
I taught him how to shoot
at both 15 weeks ago.
Couldn't be kept mixing up the difference
between, uh, is this your shop? Yeah,
this is a little pro shop in
the basement. Oh Wow. Nice.
So you set up your own bows and
everything. You level your third access,
all that stuff. No kidding.
That's great man. I love it.
So thing is just getting people won't
average Joes you get together with Jim
Miller. He's out there too,
right? He's up in a summit.
I haven't hunted with them but
we talk every once in a while.
He's another one full balls deep.
I'm working with his guys at a and w
labs right now for like attracting or
whatnot. Them in bulk.
You get a two I use,
I got a new labs and w last like a track
that got accountants and attract top of
the corn or whatever. Yeah,
so like getting him on camera.
So like I use the stuff like
the killer queue. Like I said,
it's not just getting people in
it but like guineas, local shops.
Like you told them like we don't sell
in the store to try and get a few here,
a few there. But like we don't have the,
the network to get our name out there.
So there's people like that. Right.
Supporting those. I support me.
You helped me support me
fighting and how post sta? No,
cause I got more followers than you.
So maybe somebody will click the link
for short hair now. Give it a try. Yeah,
for sure. That's awesome, man. Do you
have a perfect attitude? I would think,
you know, uh, I mean,
there's a lot of careers right
now in the hunting world.
Like a lot of guys make videos,
they post videos,
and they basically make a great
living just making hunting videos.